Ey Mannen.
(Slavic mode ACTIVATE)
Skrattar du,
förlorar du!
MANEN!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
That intro 10/10 - IGN
The rule is simple.
If you laugh,
you will lose. And uhhh...
(Swedish) And believe me, you do NOT want to lose, Man
(Actual Swedish) If you lose you will go out with five whip lashes
Okay
Okay, let's do this!
Have you accepted the challenge?
Very well, let's see if you can beat this challenge.
(upbeat Japanese dance music with singing)
(Pewds embraces inner Japanese)
(Swedish) So far I have not laughed
How did you go?
How did it go for you?
So far, so good.
So far, so good everybody.
- What is it General?
- My Lord, the fleet has moved out of light speed.
- Comm scan has detected an energy field-
Oh, it's one of these.
(Chuckle that is definitely not a skrattar.)
- Commscan has detected an energy field protecting i-
(Still totally not a skrattar)
(okay, fine, THAT'S a skrattar.)
God damn it!
(poods has lost)
God damn it, well done editing that. That's classic.
Commscan has detected an energy field-
Simpl- simple editing can really make such a huge difference.
Well done, whoever did that one,
you're probably not watching, but I'm just saying well done, because I like giving compliments...
Because I am such a... (in swedish) good person, man!
So I had a "relatively small piece" of the company, and what happened is-
Wait a second, you were chairman of the board! You were chairman of the board!
I was chairman, but I didn't run the company. I had nothing to do with running the company
Management was-
You were paid two million dollars a year.
Excuse me, I didn't run the company, I'm just telling you
So what were you paid two million dollars a year for?
(incoming bullshit) Now let me explain- excuse me! Because of my genius, okay.
AYY, hey bazinga!
*Poods Gibberish* Oh! Oh! Oh! why- why did you get paid 2 million dollars Trump...*unintelligible*
*Mumbling and fake crying*
If you get paid two million dollars for doing nothing then yes, you are a genius, I will go as far as say that
(incoming WSJ article about poods supporting Trump.)
Listen to this fucking...
*oof of realization*
Oh my god. I've become... Edit that out.
Jesus Christ.
*mock crying* Why did you get paid 2 million dollars meeeh
Look at the look of intensity on My anus (?!)
The question is...Can seven get inside My Anus?!
My Anus is gonna to be careful of a liver kick.
This is not where My Anus wants to be.
My Anus is most comfortable on the ground!
Not a good place for my anus to be...
Myanus loosen- loosen up a little here!
We know, Pat, that My Anus can take a pounding and comeback.
Interesting to see, My Anus getting a little acrobatic.
My anus wants to take him there, take him into the deep water.
So far so good for My anus.
Semmen did say yesterday; He has enormous respect for My anus.
*Pewds falls apart*
This is where My Anus wants to be, Pat!
My Anus didn't quite have the time on the ground that he wanted.
Double jab my Anus.
My anus's movement has been superb here.
MY ANUS IS TAKING P U N I S H M E N T!
ohh... I'm such a 12 year old god damn it.
What's his name? My An- Ain?
(Its "Danny Mainus")
Why would that be his name? My...I understand like Mai,
but is his last name actually Anus?
(no.)
Maybe Anis like Anis, my Anis?
(Almost there...)
You have dickhead parents, no wonder you get into boxing or UFC fighting, whatever it's called
I don't know. All I know is I would be able to beat them up, all of them, with these guns, baby.
*swole AF.
Kenan, let's watch some anime
All right, what do we got?
OOOOOOOOOOO! That's my kind of shit!
*disappointed oh*
Love is like a cock...tail.
Anime really knows how to do romance properly, like I never seen before. I think I've seen that one, actually.
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
Oh...
- Oh...cards? Oh shit!
- *intelligible* good language first of all
What do you say, we clear up our language...
and try to talk to people in a nice respectful manner?
Is that Chris-chan?
- how about you suck my f- *oof* cock?
Please see the Code of Conduct, you just got reported
for...
*laughter starts*
So what am I supposed to do?
Well man(?) you should've learned the game before you joined, huh?
This is called, what? Charades. You know what Charades is about?
I have NO idea.
Hulp...
I can't help.
Dumb-dumbs, go back to the 'Dumb-Dumb' factory.
Is this guy for real?
Buh-bye.
*laughter*
You're just a baby boy, you don't know any better.
There's so many big buttons for you to press.
*retarded laugh begins*
*retarded laugh returns*
All those big buttons. It's okay.
I'm tickling you.
Where you are the most ticklish?
*retarded laugh doesn't know when to quit*
Maybe right over here?
*Pewds' noise of disgust*
Tickle, tickle tickle
*retarded laugh prevails for the fourth time*
Tickle on the nipple.
- Tickle on the ear.
- Tickle on the nipple.
Pewds: tickle on the nipple...
- You're okay. Tickle on the nipple.
- Oh my god.
- Tickle on the ear.
*crying*
- Oh my fucking god. What the fuck just happend?
That's so creepy! fucking weirdos... Was that Chris Chan? Can someone confirm? My god. Well, I definitely lost.
(Spaghetti?)
(whats with the music...?)
(Wait...whats that?)
(The fuck...)
(wha... oh.)
(oh god no.)
(Please...)
(Fuck that shit.)
UUUWAAAAAAAAAARRRHHHHHHHH
Don't ruin Bolognese for me, please. Why would you do...euh?
Don't ruin Bolognese for me, please why would you did?
UUUWAAAAAAAAAARRRHHHHH
Come on man! Come on man! That's not cool, man!
Wait, you what?
Have you heard that meme, where th-the ting goes? BRRRRRRRRRRA
It's funny, you should look it up. That's for another whole episode
The heck is this?
Me?
That's right!
Oh!
Yes!
Never give up!
This is the new 'Just do it!' guy... Japanese Shia LaBeouf. Never give up!
Never give up! Let me see if I can do it.
What are you doing? Never give up!
Is that my phone? Do you know how fucking annoying it is? Can people just leave me alone...all the time?
*It's Brule's Rules with Dr. Steve Brule* Oh no, I've seen this one.
I'm Dr. Steve Brule will focus on genders, some people are boys and really want to be girls, some girls wanna be boys
Just be happy with your vagina...
you got it already!
Don't have to make a new one, and if you got a penis just keep it on, don't cut it off!
yOu goT iT aLReadY, dOn'T cUt iT oFf!1!
You got! This is... This is a bathtub!
(Russian Dub) Is Scott home?
Eehhh... The thing is
(approximately) Fucking hell! Fuuuuuuck!
*epic slav dance music*
Yes! These editing...are so good. That's like five different clips.
Okay four.
(its actually five)
Cyka Blyat! Skrattar du förlorar du, that's what that means (no it isn't).
*Weird ass laughter*
Okay!
*More weird ass laughter*
Some of them might, you just don't understand. I don't understand what you want from me.
"Let's face it the new YouTube sucks.
It's just not as good as what it used to be."
Yes! The Unregistered Hypercam 2! Yeah, this.
*memories of 2009 YouTube intensify*
So true.
*nasally voice* Oh, the new YouTube sucks. Now you have to censor...we're fucking swear word.
To be honest, yes, YouTube does suck and the Adpocalypse hit me pretty hard. It's terrible. I don't know what to do with  myself.
I'm gonna have to open a Patreon. It's getting real desperate :(((
*Inhales*
*Homestuck music*
Why would you like, a fucking character from Splatoon. Like what kind of pathetic, waifu's that?
Wait a minute.
Oh! No no no no no.
Aspetta (wait a second).
I cannot have this video in the video, because YouTube will then say "no, no money for you Felix"
And I'm like, but it's just an edgy joke about
Suicide. Nothing wrong with suic- no. I'm gonna move on to the next video now. Skrattar du, förlorar du
don't forget...Yeah, this fucking clip from Star Wars! Why was that in the film?
Oh my go-arhha!
And it's green, everyone is like, it's a reference to the first Star Wars, where he has blue milk.
Well, then why the hell is it green milk, and why does he drink it? It's not funny. It's gross. Like, if you're a walrus...
I-If you wanna milk a walrus, fine.
Milk a walrus, you know? First of all, not to be all vegan all preachy and shit, but milk is disgusting, it's repulsive.
You're drinking titty milk, okay?
Maybe this is, like, a commentary on the fact that how disgusting that is. All the hormones based for
calfs to grow strong. You're drinking that shit, no wonder you're growing man boobs...like a fucking weirdo. Fine! Okay, fine!
You know what, milk is fine, okay?
Let's just put that on the radar cuz I don't care...
But you have a creature that sits up like a human being. It sits up like this...
you don't see my crotch region now, but just imagine that there's four titties here and someone just sticks a can there and
It's just disgusting, it's repulsive. It's double layers. There's too many layers, and the reference thing doesn't work.
Have you like skrattat yet or not? Great.
People keep posting this one. Look at this guys. "Dank.webm"
🎵 Pour some sugar on- 🎵
Oh my god, it was salt instead of sugar, because if you pour sugar on yourself...
it doesn't hurt, but salt really hurts. That is so dank. Oh my gah!
That is hilarious. Oh my god. It was salt
I mixed up the salt and the sugar. Oh my- how could anyone do that? Oh my god!
Why am I criticizing jokes? I'm the unfunniest youtuber on this website.
-Let's talk about your options
-Okay.
- Kel?
- Yes?
- Focus.
- I am. Like, I'm listening to what you're saying, but I only hear what I want to.
- That's just called 'being a woman'.
Ooh! Thug Life! Haha,
you're a wahmen.
He's not respecting the wahmen, all right, okay? That's an outdated meme as well.
Everything is just not funny. Nothing is funny.
Well that was funny clearly. God damn it!
So stupid XD
CYKA BLYAT
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHH
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHH
Well that was, amazing, thank you. Thank you for that one, that was great. Thank you.
uuuuuugh
Okay, we finished the whole thread. Fantastic. That's two threads of garbage.
omae wa mou
shindeiru
NANI
*universe exploding holy shit*
People are memeing Star Wars even the movie's not out yet.
(japanese meme)
That's how they should have had it.
Imagine if that would happen instead of Leia just going, ''Im gonna sleep now for two hours, and then I'll be fine".
Aww damn, it was just getting good dammit. Just love dancing. Okay. That was SKRA-
TTAR
DU
FÖRLORAR DU
MANNEN
*inner slav*
Thank you very much for watching another one.
If you watch the first version of this video, congratulations,
you watched the fam- the least "family-friendly" version. If you watched version 7, then ehhh
I'm sorry, you probably didn't laugh at all.
Humor is not advertisable, what are you thinking, you stupid?
Thank you for leaving a like, let's get this one...
to 'Trending'.
I'm your host, PewDiePie, and I'll see you guys next time.